oh what a cute little puppy oh thank you  so much energy that's why I got the  longer leash go it's a federal crime to  bring an animal to a public land  Recreation Area on a leash longer than  six feet  got it  I could climb that wall over please stop  grab that elephant dude you're  embarrassing yourself you think I won't  it's time to go home I could fight a  monkey pack it in man I'll fight that  monkey it's over right there dumb  looking thing just go home I'll bet you  ten dollars I'll go in there and beat up  that monkey get him it's a federal crime  to gamble at the National Zoo  huh  [Music]  [Applause]  one frozen cherry tart please sure you  want the four inch Target or the six  inch tart I'm so sorry you wearing a  wire you rat they made me do it they  made me do it the federal crime to call  a frozen cherry pie a frozen cherry tart  if its diameter is more than four inches  [Music]